there are either of the two tools for
developing new applications
but one in particular stands ahead of
the pack
we're talking of course about the docker
configuration management tool
according to insights dice.com the
demand for software services
had bought the development operations
that is
that devops jobs into tech hiring
spotlight
the technical skills that the devops
professionals must have
are from linux fundamentals to the
devops tools like
the docker welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel
and in this particular video we will be
understanding the concept of
docker in 10 minutes but before getting
started
let's have a look at the objectives for
this lesson
in this session you will have a good
understanding of what docker is
architecture of docker major concepts of
target tool
companies using docker
and also run a few docker commands
docker is an open source
software platform used to build design
and manage
applications the purpose of introducing
docker was to make apps
work faster with docker every individual
can isolate an application from an
environment
and deploy it on another environment
using docker container
now you must be wondering what a docker
container must be
docker container is a very important
component of the docker ecosystem
docker container is an executable
software package that
includes all the dependencies such as
frameworks libraries
etc that are required to execute an
application on other environments
docker facilitates the process of
testing code faster
and reduces the time consuming process
between writing
and running a code docker does all this
with the help of containerization
that helps in deploying and managing
applications
in simple terms docker helps a user to
run code almost in every environment
whether you want to run your application
in a local machine or
on the cloud infrastructure docker
solves all your problems
with minimal effort also containers can
be moved from one hose to another
without any major changes now
let us move into our next section what
is
docker architecture docker is a client
server app docker daemon serves your
application to create
deploy shutdown etc and the docker
client communicates with the daemon
to manage its services client and server
are found in docker engine docker engine
or
docker is a client server application
that builds and executes containers
using docker components
now we know the major components of
docker what are the
other components which are used to build
and execute docker containers
well the other two components you need
to know are
the docker image and docker registry
the docker image is a template of
instructions that are used to create
containers
image is a read only pattern that is
used to build a container
the image can contain an apache tomcat
or kafka
with ubuntu operating system you can add
update and share your images an image is
built using a file called
dockerfile docker image has multiple
layers
whenever a developer builds a container
a new docker layer is automatically
created on top of image layers
and it is called as a container layer a
docker image provides a separate
read or write layer to each container
and whenever a user makes a change to
the container
that gets reflected upon the specific
container layer alone
now moving forward let's understand what
a docker registry is
docker registry is a service to the host
and it distributes
docker images amongst users a repository
is
a collection of docker images in
registry
a user can distinguish between docker
images with their tag names
docker has its own cloud-based registry
called docker hub
where users can store and distribute
container images
docker registry has public and private
repositories
in registry push and pull commands are
used to interact with docker images
the docker registry has two basic
commands one
is the push command and another is the
pull command
push command basically stores a docker
image and docker registry
whereas the pull command retrieves an
image from the docker registry
in simple terms a docker registry is a
storage
and content delivery service that holds
a bunch of docker images stored in
different tagged
versions a docker workflow is a sequence
of actions on registries
images and containers it allows a team
of developers to create containers based
on a customized image
pulled from a registry and deployed run
them
on a host server moving ahead we have
our next question that is
who uses docker increased running
capacity is just
one example of how docker is often
preferred choice over virtual machines
the famous global researcher gartner
predicts by the year 2023
more than 50 percent of the companies
will be adopting
docker containers in production however
a serverless container like docker will
have the revenue
from a small base of 465 million us
dollars in 2020
to reach to 944 million dollars in the
year 2024
let's move ahead and see what all
companies are using docker
some of the famous companies that use
docker for the growth
of their business are spotify yelp
adb ebay expedia
groupon bbc facebook
linkedin and also other companies like
the new york times
oxford university press paypal sage
shopify uses docker now
let's understand why expedia uses docker
and how does docker bring benefits to
their business
expedia has more than 9 000 docker
containers running in aws
ecs service expedia chose docker
to speed up the building and deploying
process of the application
which was possible due to the various
docker components like
docker registry and docker swarm now
let us look into the demo in which we
will be creating a docker file
and we will also be executing a few doc
commands
suppose you have set up your development
environment and the workload should be
like
first to create an image and then dock a
file
for each component of your application
we need to create containers and execute
the required commands and in the end
test share and deploy a complete
containerized
application in this demo let us focus on
step one
and step two first create a docker file
in case you have some source code and a
docker file then proceed to build your
first
docker image and ensure that the
containers which are launched from those
images
work correctly then let's check if we
already have any docker images as a
result
we can see no images are present here so
let's create a new one
to create a new docker image execute
this command
this downloading process may take a
while
now when you execute the command you can
see a list of docker images on the
screen
now among these two images let's delete
one named simplylearn
if you execute docker rm
simplylearn which is the remove command
as a result
one of your docker images will be
deleted
in case you want to remove ubuntu from
docker image
that can also be done by executing the
docker image
rm ubuntu command
moving on to the next one let's see a
few docker container commands
so now before executing container
commands
let's first pull jenkins from the docker
hub
now the files are being downloaded from
the hub
so let's wait for this full activity to
get completed
so once the process is done execute the
command
docker images here
you can see jenkins is getting
downloaded into your docker system
now let's create a container out of that
so execute the command docker create
jenkins this will help you create
a docker container now when you
execute docker ps space
hyphen a you can see a container which
is in the created mode
in case you want to start a container
execute the command
docker start file name
here our file name is tender napier
but if you want your container jenkins
to be in the running state type docker
run
jenkins now you can see the process has
started
so let's wait for a while
so this is the process of creating a
container and with that
we have come to an end of this docker in
10 minutes video
i hope it was informative and
interesting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team of experts
will be happy to resolve your queries
thanks for watching
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here